el planeta se ahoga en plástico en 2019
se generaron 460 millones de toneladas
de este material en todo el mundo esta
cifra casi duplica a lo alcanzado en el
2000 así lo señaló la organización para
la cooperación y el desarrollo económico
en su reporte denominado perspectiva
global de los plásticos el documento
también menciona que menos de una décima
parte del plástico utilizado se recicla
después de tener en cuenta las pérdidas
durante el reciclaje sólo el 9 por
ciento de los desechos plásticos
finalmente se recicla mientras que el 19
por ciento se incineró y casi el 50% se
destinó a rellenos sanitarios
el 22% restante terminó en vertederos
informales quemado al aire libre o
contaminando los mares y suelos señala
el informe que además agrega que los
plásticos contribuyeron al 3,4 por
ciento de las emisiones mundiales de los
gases de efecto invernadero en 2019 la
organización plantea iniciativas para
enfrentar esta problemática
entre ellas desarrollar el mercado de
plásticos a base de reciclados lo que
ahora sólo representa el 6 por ciento de
la producción total de plástico en gran
medida porque son más caros
la ocde aboga por un ciclo de vida más
circular de este material y puntualiza
que las políticas deben frenar su uso
es crucial que los países respondan al
desafío con soluciones coordinadas y
globales se acrecienta la necesidad de
que las naciones se unan para empezar a
buscar un acuerdo global que aborde este
problema tan importante
el informe se publica menos de una
semana del inicio de la asamblea de las
naciones unidas para el medio ambiente
programada para el 28 de febrero en
nairobi donde se espera que inicien las
conversaciones formales acerca de un
futuro tratado internacional sobre los
plásticos